was zum teil geht ja kundschaft von
meinem freund karat sofort ich dachte du
wirst sie herzlich kommen sondern wurde
direkt mit einem neuen hippen erfolge
ich habe mir einen neuen hilfen der
klassiker für uns ausgesucht also eine
von den hilfen wir folgen mit den
meisten aufrufen von 1
die folge ist natürlich wie es von mir
kennt menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend heißt der böse zwilling und
handelt von zwei zwillingen und livia
und finja die genau gleich aussehen aber
einer von den beiden ist relativ normal
und die andere ist komplett gestört
aber seht selbst heute wir starten
direkt rein ich hoffe euch gefallen die
täglichen abläufe im dezember wenn ihr
irgendwelche videowirtschaft was immer
wieder machen sagt ich habe mir das
gerne und in den kommentaren wir laden
jetzt täglich hoch also wenn wir viel
platz für neue videos und ja jetzt wo
wir das geklärt haben
fangen wir auch direkt an ok also wir
starten direkt mit einer sehr
fragwürdigen szene in dieses video rein
was sehen wir hier wir sehen schon mal
die beiden zwillinge olivia und finde
ich wie gesagt ich habe diese folge
tatsächlich noch nicht gesehen habe nur
die ersten zehn sekunden angeschaut aber
so wie es aussieht geht der freund von
der alm mit der zwillingsschwester von
ihr fremd war wahrscheinlich moment
moment ein klassischer fall ich bin mir
sicher alle von euch die zwillinge sind
das heißt die vielleicht männlich sind
und männlichen zwilling haben oder weil
bisschen weiblichen zwillingen haben
kenne dieses
natürlich passiert tagtäglich in
deutschland tausend mal deswegen vielen
dank hilft mir der rtl2 dass ich das
hier mal aufgearbeitet habe natürlich
kann der freund von einem zwilling ihn
nicht vom anderen zwilling unterscheiden
ich hatte keine stelle das mal vor leute
ihr seid einer von zwei zwilling und so
eure freunde darauf leuten ist einfach
so
ja ich wusste nicht was nicht schon
recht ähnlich aus geht es einfach so
sagt der erwartung dass sie dann sagt
ach so ach du dachtest ich wäre sie da
das kann natürlich mal passieren wir
sind ja auch erst seit acht jahren
zusammen
also ich muss wirklich sagen hatte ich
habe vor beginnt dieser folge noch keine
gehirnzellen warnung ausgegeben
das sollte ich eigentlich machen in
meiner verantwortung als youtuber euch
vorher waren das euch diese folge
vermutlich wieder um einiges an hirn
kapazität berauben wird und so wie es
bis dato aussieht ist es auch genau so
also es kam mir realtech es macht spaß
beiseite
keiner erzählen dass man mit einem
zwilling zusammen ist aus versehen mit
dem ansatz willing was hat ist sie ist
einfach so sie lacht mich weil sie ihre
schwester ihre zwillingsschwester man
die waren zusammen im bauch ihrer mutter
zum gleichen zeitpunkt nicht deswegen
weil sie sie verarscht hat also damit
ihren freund was gemacht hat sondern sie
denkt sie einfach so kann eigentlich
nicht sein das ist das i
okay was hat sie gesagt sie kann nichts
dafür dass ihr freund so ein wurst ist
so ein wurst so so eine wurst ist die
wurst nicht dass wurst aber also ich
weiß nicht wie du versuchen bisschen
vernunft oder zumindest korrekte
deutsche grammatik hier in dieser folge
reinzubringen
seid nicht sauer auf mich heute ja sagen
wir mal lieber dankbar sagen wir mal
lieber dankbar dafür dass du jetzt nicht
mit deinem freund zusammen sein muss die
du geliebt hast du mit denen du die eine
gemeinsame zukunft vorgestellt als alter
schnell mal vor ich hätte das nicht
gemacht so verstehen diesen gefallen
nicht getan
du bist halt immer noch glücklich mit
ihm das ist also seid doch froh dass du
nicht mehr glücklich sein kann
ja ich glaube jeder mensch der noch
einen funken verstand läuft im kopf hat
er noch ein paar gehirnzellen irgendwo
da drin ganz hinten drin hat er sich
auch schon einige hilfe folgen gezogen
hat und schon wirklich viel an grauer
masse verloren hat aber dennoch ein
bisschen was im kopf hat der kann nicht
anders als festzustellen dass der
komplette handlungsrahmen auf dem diese
folge gebaut ist also ok also wir wissen
jetzt dass finja die böse von den beiden
ist finja war die die mit diesem du da
gerade in bettlach olivia ist die gute
der beiden schwestern ich will
vielleicht mal diese welt an und sinne
der wir uns gerade schon wieder befinden
kurz stoppen auch mal wirklich zu sagen
also real realtech leute das ist somit
einer der logen moves die man als mensch
in seinem leben machen kann mit dem
freund oder der freundin von seinem
eigenen blut seiner eigenen schwester
seinen bruder was anzufangen
ich bin mir leider relativ sicher dass
sowas schon ab und zu mal passiert in
deutschland aber das ist wirklich das
allerletzte was es gibt richtig gemacht
und sich erst mich ausgegeben um leon
ist bei so viel wie konnte er es nicht
merken
ja das ist tatsächlich eine frage die
ich mir auch stelle einfach wenn irgend
ein männlicher darsteller irgendwie
hilfen erfolgen erscheint das kannst du
bitte noch mal sagen ich muss mich sagen
das level an dreistigkeit ist schon
relativ stark ich sehe heute gleich aus
er kriegt so nach lässt dabei aber kann
man den darsteller wirklich nicht übel
nimmt also stelle ich mir vor ebenso der
folgende müsste zu spielen dass ich
werde die ganze immer das gleiche sagen
leute aber wir müssen uns das wirklich
verkaufen muss einfach laut drehbuch
sagen dass er den ein zwilling nicht vom
anderen auseinander gehalten hat und
dass er sich so denke ich konnte
bitte hör mich an meine bitte haben mir
zu
oder bist du bis zum song
das macht wahrscheinlich sind also okay
er ist eigentlich kein mensch ist kein
darsteller sondern er ist ein song zum
neuer song von von kapital und seine
aufgabe so werben für sich selbst
bitte habe ich mal ich bin wirklich ich
habe eine gute melodie und ein betreuer
mich an
kannst du kannst du vielleicht noch kurz
denn den t shirt an behalten also hält
also ich meine aber wenn ich jetzt mal
die anderen anschauen so die haben schon
ein bisschen längere klamotten an so
sieht schon so aus ist wer so herbst
oder winter so dem alle jacken und
pullis also der kamera ist kameras auch
mir okay ich nein also front aber wenn
man jeden tag trainiert sieht man noch
ein bisschen anders aus aber okay okay
ich will ja nicht zu sehr irgendwie
diese folgen korrigieren und versuchen
irgendwie sind auszumachen
wie wärs denn hiermit leute so also ich
hab ich mal vor so ihr habt einen freund
vor langer zeit mit dem so volk wirklich
voll verliebt und dann geht ihr euch
fremd was macht ihr halbe stunde später
seid ihr so auf die schule im alter aber
der ist auch mega ich so was ist
emotionaler schmerz nach einer trennung
so alle anderen monate lang vielleicht
drauf warum sie bedeckten nächsten
lassen sie nicht an ausspannen kann
[Musik]
ja okay okay okay okay natürlich sport
direkt der böse zwillinge also es
scheint wirklich direkt in dem moment
die erklärung dafür dass der böse
deswegen direkt erscheinen kann ist ja
dass er wirklich direkt neben stand so
drei meter die ganze zeit aber ja sie
erscheint in dem moment in dem ihre
schwester irgendeine art von interesse
an dem anderen mann zeigen ist so ok
hier fällt dann kann ich wieder
ausspannen
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt ein ganzes wissen
vorgespräche leute weil mir ganz viel
unsinn da mittendrin war aber nächste
szene literally so die liebe von den
beiden schild mit ihrem neuen schwarm
also wir haben ja schon festgestellt
dass man wenn man so krass betrogen
wurde
das ist innerhalb von einem halben tag
wieder vergisst das wissen wir alle aber
sieht es mit ihrem neuen freund zu
wissen auf der couch zum gewissen amrum
machen und ja dann und dann erscheint
ihre schwester einfach wieder so im raum
können wir dafür immer irgendwie der
begründung haben wir war die wahl der
böse zwingen auf hogwarts oder so kann
er parieren
fritschi kurz bitte ohne vip skill ganz
kurz so die die vier sind jetzt zu neuen
hogwarts zu ja die haben jetzt gerade
das parieren gelernt also dass sie sich
halt mit ihrem zauberstab einfach an
jedem ort teleportieren können jetzt
müssen die das jedem zeigen weiß ja wie
hogwarts schüler sind kleinen patzern
also leute was lernen wir daraus wenn
ihr eine schwester habt die euch relativ
ähnlich seid dann achtet wirklich darauf
dass die nicht nach frau kurz kommt wenn
der brief von hogwarts kommt so dass sie
da eingeladen
das ist saubere lernen soll dann keine
ahnung verriegelt einfach gleis 9 drei
viertel sowie tobias gemacht hat das ist
glaube ich die beste art und weise
vielen dank für diese wertvolle lektion
an die ratgeberserie hilft mir wie
gesagt heute schon sehr gerne eure video
wird schon in die kommentare reichen die
bekommt hier ein für euch
vorstellungsvideo hier oben könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ich das machen wollte es
kostenlos für euch so wieder
meine stimme kurz verpackt für eine
schule raus wichtig einen schönen tag
größere augen macht's gut weiter